hey guys it's dense the founder thing
here I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of well not a review
discussion right now of the newly
released Batman picture is like the
first picture that we've seen the new
Batman right the Man of Steel to zack
snyder batfleck the ben affleck playing
batman at first you know we saw that
Zack Snyder had released a picture of
the Batmobile little cover yesterday
yeah covered up and so no one had
assumed that we were gonna see the
actual Batman suit we thought okay we're
gonna see the full Batmobile yeah
tomorrow but instead we got a big
surprise which was not only we see the
Batmobile we saw the new batsuit which
is very frank miller the Dark Knight
Returns inspired very uh what do you
think of it it looks good I mean I I
guess it's funny like this news
obviously rocked Twitter's on us okay I
it's weird I don't want to sound like
like a hater I'm not it looks fine I
like Frank Miller so I think watch watch
them Warner Bros animation just did
parts one in part they did a two-part
dark knight returns you know animated
movie you would watch that it's awesome
but I guess because we've had so much
Batman lately I'm not hungry for Batman
right now I mean we just say Christopher
Nolan's trilogy wrapped up about a year
ago so like I saw it it looks cool but
didn't like shake me like oh man like
that's awesome but it looks good i'm
happy with the direction ago and i love
the the little bat ears like the Frank
Miller's got the small area and even has
at husky look he look at husky not like
lean and true i don't know how what size
Affleck's were how much weight he's
gaining but he looks like a little
huskier which i like i like i like that
story i just want to fear of batman
stories yeah yeah for sure how about you
I mean were you like we saw it with like
oh this is cool or did I mean what did
you think when you saw I thought it
looked really cool you know I mean I for
me because you know I am a big fan of
dark knight returns so when I saw it I
was like oh total frat Miller style with
the short year and the logo if you see
the logo big both like I don't know if
you guys seen it which I'll put up the
picture but like there was the initial
picture and then there was a picture
that people tweak that raised all the
the brightness value
yeah that you would see in more detail
the suits and the logo but the logo is
totally from you know the dark knight
returns right yeah and definitely the
short years there were I'd say in
general mostly positive responses like
on my Facebook and on Twitter were
mostly positive sure there were a few
people that did had complaints and some
people you know I saw some people it's
terrible they didn't like the short ears
you know they didn't like that at all
they don't say it often in comics no and
they thought he was too fat and bubble I
thought it looked pretty good i like i
like the look of it you know and I you
know it's the direction they're going
they're going with the the older you
know Dark Knight Returns type of Batman
I mean Ben Affleck is 40 something they
want to make it he's not a kid anymore
yeah this isn't a young Batman and I
like to what I liked about it is I mean
until real all not recently but less
like you know a few decades I mean like
I love Bruce Tim's version of Atma and
Batman the Animated Series cuz he was
kind of why I'll be led big wide
shoulders he wasn't jacked like six pack
cut I mean he was a big strong do kind
of like um what I really grant Morse's
interpretation of Superman you read all
star superman yeah Frank quietly did the
art for that I loved how he had
Superman's is kind of big husky
Midwestern boy are from Kansas a farm
boy not some guy who works out the gym
and looks perfect like I I kind of
prefer that look I think but I think he
looks cool it has a 40 year old purse
like I said yeah Ben Affleck is not a
kid anymore so I mean I think it works
yeah and he's also got he's got tools
she's got a squarish yeah and if it sees
yeah he is a bit wider as they have
people were complaining about that yeah
they were looking for a more armor
tactical look oh but I mean I think the
suit is gonna be it's it's gonna be some
sort of Kevlar you know yeah yeah or
Kevlar like he had the utility belt as
well okay this is one random thing that
that people were saying yeah I think
it's just maybe a coincidence there is
like in the corner I'll zoo I'll put up
a picture here and zoom in on this there
is like in the corner like all the joke
yeah basically it kind of looks like a
joker face right and so it's like is
that coincidence or is that like they
did on purpose or it just happened to be
that that
smoke in the Batmobile kind of made that
or maybe it's just an easter egg that
whoever was doing the photoshop on this
did that yeah I guess somebody that yeah
but yeah that's a good question because
I mean that could you wonder what
directors that they're building up we
know just the movies confirmed yes there
it's green that it's going to happen so
yeah what cracks me of us isn't this
supposed to be a Superman sequel yeah in
a Lex Luthor Lex Luthor that's what
friends like this seems like it's
turning more into like a Batman movie
scene and where's Henry Cavill I mean we
know what enrrique apple looks like we
know what the student looks like but
let's show up it's your Henry Cavill
like we've seen it's like it's like it's
like a new Batman movie as opposed to a
Superman movie well see the thing is is
before earlier in our conversation you
had mentioned you're like oh we've had
enough Batman see the thing is is like
fans do not get enough of Batman no
that's the thing is like they can eat a
Batman all day all night so for them
like yes people in general like the the
Man of Steel reboot or whatever this new
universe they liked it there I mean
there were some people that didn't but
in general it made a lot of money people
are looking forward to it but when it
comes down to it that man's always the
biggest seller yes in the comic book
store Superman vs Batman yeah it's
always bad look at my Batman comics
though yeah Superman does not super he
has a few and there's like no yeah
Batman is always a more popular all the
all the newest fad DC animated movies
have all been Batman son of batman just
came out the video games video games
either games all Batman there's a rumor
that rocks Eddie who developed the you
know Arkham City games is developing the
Superman story but that's there's still
no word of that because it's hard
Superman stories are hard to do yeah
what's of what's he gonna do if he
doesn't have a bat cave to be like oh
here's these different areas i'm gonna
go cover he just flies it you know
zubrin's not tactical no it's flies and
kicks punches people you're so powerful
like yeah you know the common criminal
doesn't really do anything for you so
I'll be curious is the movie you know
keeps going through production would be
close to the release date if we're gonna
start seeing eventually we'll see Henry
Cavill of course but like how much are
they going to keep teasing more Batman
but I guess he's the bigger news because
we've seen henry cavill's superman we
know what he can do we haven't seen Ben
after that means like I did that is and
I just
think that man in general is all your
father's always bigger news because even
when the new Super Man of Steel they did
the Mayor was to make dark knight money
no not only that the the fervor around
it when they like show the first super
Henry Cavill in the suit did not make
these kind of ways no and it's like when
like Twitter was going nuts right there
this thing what do you think is a
Batmobile looks good it's a like a
combination of Nolan and Burton Burton
you know which i think is perfect
because I like that Nolan try to make
Batman like how we would really be in
the real world and you probably wouldn't
have a thing looks like a Batmobile you
probably have like this armored tank
exact but then I also Tim Burton movie
the first one you know it looks cool I
love the look at that one aerodynamic
it's got like the shield you know
shields come on that was my favorite
Batmobile ever so I like the kind of
combining the two yeah it's kind of got
the look of the Burton one with the fins
in the front where the the window is but
it has the big giant tumblr style yeah
so I think it's a I think they're paying
homage to both both sides I think it's
good nice smaller though it does like
only like one person can probably yeah
it's not gonna have like a he's uncle to
put you know kim basinger see like
Michael Keaton did back in the day but
no it was good I liked it alright guys
so that's what we thought of the new
Batman suit and Batmobile let us know
what you think cuz i know you guys have
tons of peanut do you love it did you
hate it I noticed yeah I think most of
people who didn't like the short ears
probably have never read The Dark Knight
Returns we the daughter returns Frank
Miller and in the mid 80s yeah so yeah
let us know what you thought you can
post your constable on our website thing
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
carroll pro make sure to subscribe to
that you guys are gonna find us on
twitter jenison myself rat think hero
i'm at griffin de and we also a facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero fans and make sure you like our
videos and share them on twitter
facebook all that stuff
you